[Musique]
merci de votre fidélité au journal de
l'Afrique très heureuse de vous
retrouver Kibumba aux portes de Goma
n'est plus aux mains du M23 la ville est
une des positions stratégiques dans le
Nord qui vous la région théâtre vous le
savez d'affrontement récurrents entre
Kigali et King Charles les conclusions
du dialogue inter guinéen ne font pas
l'unanimité l'âge pour être candidat à
la présidentielle par exemple nous
verrons pourquoi et puis on s'est faite
de fin d'année nous goûterons du foie
gras made in Égypte rencontre enfin
d'édition avec un exploitant belge qui
destine ses produits au touristes
fortunés
faut-il y voir une accalmie dans la
guerre qui sévit dans l'Est de la RDC
les rebelles du M23 se sont retirés de
kibomba et ils l'ont fait savoir
cérémonie journaliste camera conviés la
ville et stratégique à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Gomma la capitale du Nord
qui vit qui vous c'est la force
régionale de la Communauté des États
d'Afrique de l'Est qui en prend
désormais le contrôle sur place Aurélie
bazarra qui bangoula
la cérémonie très solennelle a duré un
peu moins d'une heure le major sensei
Imany l'un des chefs du M23 a remis
officiellement le contrôle de Kibumba au
représentant de la force régionale
d'Afrique de l'Est alors kibomba c'est
l'une des positions stratégiques du M23
occupé depuis mi-novembre stratégique
parce qu'elle est située à moins d'une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Goma lors de
cette cérémonie le M23 a réitéré sa
demande un dialogue direct avec les
autorités congolaises pour je cite
trouver une solution durable
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour le
Congo l'Afrique de l'Est et pour
l'Afrique en général notre retrait
marque le début de notre volonté a
quitté les territoires que nous
contrôlons pour le respect des
engagements pris par les chefs d'État de
la région
nous sommes donc en bon chemin vers la
paix vers le processus de comme c'était
prévu
le commandant de la Force régionale le
major kenyang Jeff Nyanga a salué ce
premier pas en avant ce retrait du M23
de kibomba intervient alors que la
pression diplomatique est s'accentue sur
le Rwanda l'armée rwandaise est accusée
d'avoir fourni des armes des munitions
et des uniformes aux rebelles du M23
pour mener des opérations militaires sur
le territoire congolais c'est ce
qu'affirme des experts des Nations unies
dans un nouveau rapport qui n'est pas
encore publié mais que nous avons pu
consulter un soutien rwandais au
rebelles du M23 également dénoncé par
les États-Unis et plusieurs pays
européens une source gouvernementale
congolaise nous expliquait prendre acte
de ce retrait mais rappelle que les
rebelles du M23 doivent se retirer de
toutes les zones
occupées conformément aux décisions
prises lors du mini sommet de Luanda
Barbara Manzi n'est plus la bienvenue au
Burkina Faso l'italienne qui coordonnait
les travaux de l'ONU depuis août 2021 et
sommé par la jante de quitter le pays au
plus tôt motif des propos qui auraient
terminé l'image du pays et des décisions
prises Unies latéralement écoutez les
explications formulées par la ministre
burkinabé des Affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui nous recevons une note
justement de Barbara et qui fait que
l'évacuation des familles diplomates du
système des Nations Unies pour raison
sécuritaire et nous à notre niveau nous
trouvons que c'est vraiment inconcevable
la décision était uniquement prise nous
n'avons pas
les syndicateurs irréatifs et au-delà et
le Président
Ibrahim Traoré a contacté et le
secrétaire général coûteraise avant-hier
et qui dit ne pas être au courant d'une
telle décision et pour votre information
le ministre délégué et moi on a reçu un
audience une fois et Madame
chef terroriste au Burkina
et les preuves sont légion parce que
elle va un turbo elle revient comme elle
le veut alors que nous le force de
défense et de sécurité même ne peuvent
pas effectuer ce genre de déplacement
35 ans au minimum 75 ans maximum c'est
la proposition retenue à l'issue des
discussions interguées pour être
candidat à la présidentielle de quoi
écarter Cydia Touré l'opposant ancien
Premier ministre à Conakry les
explications de Malik Diakité
cette proposition est adoptée par le
Conseil National de la Transition
l'organe qui fait office de Parlement
elle écarte automatiquement de la cause
présidentielle Sidia Touré l'opposant au
pouvoir militaire actuel âgé de 77 ans
il est le président de l'Union des
Forces Démocratiques de Guinée le parti
considéré comme la troisième force
politique du pays une situation que
dénoncé militants mais aussi des acteurs
de la société civile ils ont fait quelle
étude pour vous qui scientifiquement à
75 ans on n'est plus apte à diriger ils
ont fait quel référence conventionnelle
de par le monde quel est le modèle de
démocratie dans le monde où ils ont
puisé sur la ils veulent nous mener sur
un chemin extrêmement dangereux pour
notre démocratie pour le président du
Mouvement des patriotes pour le
développement qui a pris par au dialogue
cette décision ne cible personne en
particulier elle ne vise aux personnes
elle ne vise donc pas un parti politique
parce que nous avons pensé à la Guinée
avons travaillé en dehors des
considérations politiques partisanes en
dehors de considération idéologies nous
avons mis au-dessus de nos chapelles
politiques et bien entendu la Guinée les
principaux partis politiques et membres
de la société civile qui ont boycoté ce
dialogue contre appelé a des
manifestations de rue pour demander un
retour rapide des civils au pouvoir
les dégâts sont importants mais il n'y a
pas eu de victimes un incendie c'est
déclaré dans un entrepôt de gaz de
Mohammedia dans l'ouest du Maroc pour
une raison encore inconnue une enquête a
été ouverte des images impressionnantes
que nous comporte Caroline Lamboley
des flammes et en nuages de fumée
immense ces images ont fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux marocains jeudi soir
l'explosion était très puissante
les habitants qui vivent à côté ont eu
peur et ce sont mis à paniquer
il y avait des personnes âgées des
enfants et aussi des voitures garé à
côté trois voitures ont brûlé on a eu
peur car les explosions étaient
puissantes comme des bombes qui
tombaient du ciel
les pompiers avaient déjà maîtrisé
l'incendie qui s'était déclaré dans un
grand dépôt de gaz près de Casablanca il
n'y a pas eu de victimes près de 24
heures plus tard les circonstances ne
sont toujours pas claires
il y avait une fuite de gaz
c'est un mystère
on se demande si le feu est parti d'un
briquet ou d'une cigarette c'est ça la
question
citerne ont été détruits dans l'incendie
les autorités marocaines ont ouvert une
enquête
limiter la déforestation en Ouganda
c'est le défi que c'est lancé un réfugié
Sud soudanais comment enseignant aux
communautés locales des techniques de
reboisement Laurent Berchet
en 2017 au pire abosco doit fuir son Sud
Soudan natal déchiré par une violente
guerre civile arrivé en Ouganda le jeune
homme se voit attribuer une parcelle de
terre et si construite en abri mais
aujourd'hui impossible pour les autres
réfugiés d'en faire autant car la forêt
a presque entièrement disparu au pirates
ces données pour mission de reboiser le
plus possible tout en sensibilisant les
communautés au danger de la
déforestation
je leur montre comment entretenir les
arbres comment choisir l'espace pour les
replanter et pour qu'il pousse
correctement et aussi comment limiter la
déforestation
en 2020 au pirates font une association
pour éduquer et soutenir les jeunes
réfugiés en nouvelle
il enseigne également les bonnes
pratiques environnementales notamment
des techniques de reboisement et
d'économies d'énergie
aujourd'hui nous avons une nouvelle
méthode on prend des arbres pour
remplacer ce que nous pouvons
le reboisement est crucial pour
préserver et protéger l'environnement
mais aussi pour limiter les conflits et
les guerres autour des ressources
naturelles des violences qui deviennent
de plus en plus fréquentes dans la Corne
de l'Afrique en proie à une sécheresse
historique
on s'est faite de fin d'année il est de
nombreuses tables occidentales le foie
gras mais c'est dans son pays d'origine
que je vous emmène l'Egypte et oui c'est
sur les bords du Nil que la technique de
gavage a vu le jour il y a plus de 4500
ans Michel Mosser s'est installé comme
producteur près de Louxor et ravi d'une
clientèle aisée rencontre signé Édouard
Dropsy et Justine Babin
c'est ici dans cette ferme au bord de la
mer Rouge que Michel mossert a installé
son exploitation de canard à l'approche
des fêtes il supervise le gavage d'un
millier de volailles destiné à la
production de foie gras
donc c'est du canard mulard comme dans
le Sud-Ouest
en Égypte le gavage se pratique depuis
l'antiquités
[Musique]
pour éviter la propagation de la grippe
aviaire qui avait touché énormément de
producteurs dans les années 2000
l'Egypte a décidé d'interdire l'élevage
en tonnerre quitte à moins se soucier du
bien-être animal alors les conditions
sont moins sympa que si j'étais dehors
mais s'il était dehors il serait malade
donc ça serait pire en fait puisque la
grippe aviaire et donc en les gardant à
l'intérieur on empêche on limite ses
contacts avec les
oiseaux sauvages et donc on permet de ça
permet de contrôler bien mieux la
diffusion du virus
installée à Hurghada au bord de la mer
Rouge Michel propose ses produits à une
clientèle touristique étrangère ce soir
des plongeurs rentrent d'une semaine de
croisière
à l'époque des pyramides on a des
fresques où on voit les Égyptiens à
genoux qui gave les oies une par une
et ils sont agréablement surpris
es
[Musique]
si le foie gras vient à manquer en front
pour les fêtes ce ne sera pas le cas en
Égypte pour les quelques privilégiés qui
pourront se l'offrir
et c'est sur cette note gustative que se
termine ce journal de l'Afrique merci de
l'avoir suivi merci également à
kalidouci à l'édition et aux équipes en
régie je vous souhaite d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année prenez soin de vous
et de vos proches pour ma part pour voir
en 2023 rester sur France 24
[Musique]